yeah no that's real
um yo what is like for you because
obviously La is you know you have like I
said I mean you got Classics bro
when you look at the metrics what is
your biggest Market outside of the State
of California
oh no I think I need to pay more
attention to that you got to put that
back in on Spotify man yeah what about
like when you were on not like
last time you're on tour did you notice
like a random City where you were like
oh [ __ ] they were really [ __ ] with me
in so and so or wherever it's hard to
tell because my energy is everyone's
[ __ ] with you yeah like once I'm done
it's like everybody
my energy is Electrify yeah so they [ __ ]
with me it's like hard to tell like if
they knew the words already right right
right and my songs are you know I know
how to tell hooks yeah I mean I know how
to tell a story I know how to speak to
the audience you know so I can get them
to say what's going on because you know
what I'm saying my message is pure so
like it's kind of hard as far as when
I'm performing and touring but
um I I honestly I do need to pay more
attention to who's
because I want to tackle these cities
more you know I'm an LA head of course
we out here you know trying to you know
I deal with the same pains that my
homies deal with I'm not gone I'm not
too far I'm not far-fetched I'm you know
I'm here they can touch me and [ __ ] so
it's kind of like I deal with the same
deaths the same Joy the same
accomplishments you know I mean like
when my homies is up and they winning I
see that and I feel that you feel me so
I'm just right here so I feel like
um sometimes you could be trapped
do you feel like you sometimes you can
get lost in the sauce of LA and not
think of like the the country
because I feel like sometimes I could
never be lost in sauce man well you know
I don't mean listen I'm not talking
about from a Gucci Mane perspective okay
no you can't you could let me lost in
the summer
[Laughter]
something about America have they can
have sauce but he could be you know I'm
saying if you don't got sauce you lost
in the sauce you feel me like no do you
ever feel like do you ever feel like um
you know what's going on you like I'm
just playing
you stuck out you could focus too much
on La and and and at times let the
bigger picture Fall by the wayside
because I do feel like sometimes an LA
artist we see like a ceiling get hit and
it's like yo we know you're lit from
here to Seattle Arizona Vegas right
sometimes Texas but like I think
sometimes like La artists are so like
focused on La that it's not I'm not even
talking about sonically I just mean like
you said earlier like damn I need to pay
attention more like you know uh
something that Kailyn did early on that
I loved was like he just went out to
Atlanta for like six months you know
yeah he was out there like he was out
there you know what I mean he tapped in
with a lot like I I I saw that from the
jump and I was like oh that's that's
something I see a lot of people doing
that um blue box do that yeah
um you know he does you know definitely
does that
um Caitlyn of course did that um
another person who did it mozzie did
that [ __ ] big time you know what I'm
saying he did that but I don't know bro
oh you know I'm good [ __ ] I'm having fun
that's all that matters feeding your
family feeding my family I'm having fun
I'm enjoying life
um I I cross those but you know what I'm
saying I once when I get through those
Crossroads then for sure I do need to
pay attention to it though for sure you
know what I'm saying and when I get
there I'll get there but right now I got
right here to deal with you know it's
people that I have to deal with I have
to you know make sure they straight I
have to make sure people are saying
right times you know what I'm saying
sometimes when I'm gone too long you
know [ __ ]
[ __ ] up you know what I'm saying it
ruptures and [ __ ] like that like so I
hold a lot of [ __ ] together and and I
stand on that and I could I could you
know what I'm saying if if you know if
yet they blow up and he gets you know
I'm saying to you know uh New York and
all that [ __ ] for sure that's I'm you
know we we there you know I feel like
two hit like sonically he's like an
artist that I could see that really
happening with right
I feel like he has that young soul that
uh
the world needs
um I feel like he has that that
hunger that the world needs to you know
I'm saying experience for sure